keiner meiner kumpels hatten ich bin
jetzt tot
naja gut muss ich einfach gucken ich
glaub ich mache es auch einfach mal zwei
hoch aber dafür seien extra raum hier
irgendwie damit das nicht so nicht
eskaliert sage ich mal
also erde haben wir genug er da kann ich
eigentlich hier schon mal so eine so
eine promo ein bisschen vorlage von
einer farm aufbauen ich mir vorgestellt
hatte
was brauchen wir denn eigentlich noch so
ach ich kann er aber kurz der pelzfarmen
und co ja da kann ich auch schon mal
abhaken
weil das werden wir zu machen finde erde
von von ein zusätzlicher nord ich kann
da erstmal eins von zwei haben wir schon
ende märz haben wir auch noch nicht
stonebridge kräften beinhauer das haben
wir auch schon okay wegpunkte muss ich
noch setzen stimmt und ich würde auch
sagen dass uns erst mal wieder so ein
paar neue sachen machen die wir brauchen
hab ich noch habe ich noch sehr gut also
aus stein jetzt neue werkzeuge und so
weiter wenn ihr versteht was ich meine
ich brauch mal was zu kämpfen hier
achtet knochenmehl da gleich drauf
packen fällt mir grad auf zwei watt was
brauche ich dann alles schwert habe ich
eine schaufel mehr wo ich gar nicht auch
den soundtrack können wir machen
dafür brauche ich aber eigentlich nur
vier cobblestone das sollte reichen für
das war irgendwie finde ich das schon
richtig schön dass wir uns hier
aufgebaut haben
jetzt muss ich echt mal so sagen
holz brauche ich definitiv dass wir
gleich fällen gehen oder hatte ich noch
wert nicht eine schaufel sonst brauche
ich eigentlich gar nichts mehr
das sonic ist die kiste karriere
theoretisch noch vergrössern hier
einfach so aus lust und laune
was brauchen wir denn wir benötigen
zweimal in der firma braun holz also
sticks für zäune und die nehme ich
einfach mit weil wir dann gleich direkt
neue bäume pflanzen werden
das heißt bäume fällen bedeutete
ungeduldige youtube gelingen könnte ja
auch mal eben bei seinem thema reden hat
mir gerade mal so einfällt und zwar fifa
vielleicht werde ich das ganze noch mal
irgendwann in dem konto besprechen was
der kontakt ist sollte allen bewusst
sein mittlerweile der welt dann
eventuell noch mal besprechen was wenn
sie meine meinung zu fifa 13 ist bisher
und so also wie gesagt vielleicht werde
ich das besprechen aber ich kann das ja
auch erstmal jetzt sagen denn das haben
wir leute bei facebook bei meiner
facebook seite facebook.com / von
crafter tv steht auch in der
beschreibung
also wenn ihr dass da wirklich leid
sagte er endlich immer so dabei wenn ich
irgendwie ein paar aktionen mache wenn
ich irgendwie online bei steam mit ein
paar leuten spiele oder usw
wann videos kommen wir nicht aber sorry
aber jedenfalls hab mir da ein typ
geschrieben als ich ein bild von fifa 13
gepostet meinte er
hey was ist denn deine meinung wer so
jetzt zu fifa 13 ich mir gedacht ist
eigentlich ganz gutes thema worüber ich
mal ein bisschen quatschen könnte und
zwar ist das gerade hier der perfekte
zeitpunkt ein bisschen bäume abbauen
bisschen klein bisschen quadratischen
hier l 413 ist für mich eigentlich finde
ich ziemlich geil ist es auch eigentlich
immer relativ egal was die jetzt neu
machen ob das jetzt nur ganz partnerin
änderungen sind ich meine ich kaufe mir
jedes fifa egal was daran neu ist
weil ich einfach immer das aktuellste
haben möchte und vor allem diesmal hätte
ich mir auch alleine schon gekauft wenn
es nur diese virtuelle bundesliga
gegeben hätte weil das finde ich
allgemein auch schon extrem geil dass er
da wirklich
früher gab es da war das wirklich nur so
dass man wenn man online gespielt hat
kriegt man punkt und dadurch wird man
den ligen geordnet aber die virtuelle
bundesliga findet nur in deutschland
statt
von ea organisiert und habe ich schon
gesagt ist eine virtuelle bundesliga das
heißt ich bin zurzeit noch in liga drei
mittlerweile zum zeitpunkt der aufnahme
und man kann dann halt immer weiter
aufsteigen sage ich mache indem man
spiele gewinnt und dann gibt es halt
nicht mehr diese ganzen live es gibt
natürlich immer noch erfahrungspunkte
und sowas aber dann gibt es halt nicht
mehr diese ganzen dieses komische
ranglisten system sondern einfach es
gibt liegen wo man aufsteigt und wo man
auch wieder absteigt das find ich
eigentlich ganz cool weil ich bin in der
dritten gerade und das hessen wirklich
alle gegner relativ schlecht und ich
glaube wenn man in der ersten liga ist
oder so wird man auf der seite von ea
sports von line wird man dann irgendwie
in der rangliste dort angezeigt also
deutschlandweit und das finde ich
eigentlich extrem geil dass man wirklich
so ein faktor hat so acom okay dass
wieder einer form einer rangliste da
muss ich auch mal wieder ein spiel
machen dann wieder überholt man den
wieder und das ist eigentlich ganz
interessanter faktor ich hoffe ich
konnte ich das jetzt ein bisschen
erklären also wird es mir erklärt kann
auch ein bisschen anders sein aber ich
glaube so grob stimmt die richtung
erstmal und das finde ich eigentlich
schon extrem geil und nur deswegen hätte
ich mir das auch schon gekauft und
allgemein halt immer wenn irgendwie
kumpels bei einem sind es wird wirklich
immer fifa gezockt bei mir irgendwie vor
trinken oder irgendwie sohn dann gehen
wir nachher irgendwohin dann wirklich
erstmal fifa hat ein bisschen aufregend
es ganz witzig und allein deswegen weil
ich einfach jedes fifa und es gibt auch
in dieser streit fifa börse space pasta
viel besser ist eigentlich ein fifa sein
dass die die lizenzen von allen
vereinbar haben blabla
sonst können die ja nix hier von ea also
ich finde es sagt ja schon was das fifa
einfach deutlich mehr exemplare verkauft
als pro evolution soccer
das ist ja eigentlich schon grund genug
aber ich finde auch einfach das ist
allein durch diese lizenzen ist
ihm ist es viel viel geiler als platz
allein schon wegen der lizenz das kann
man nicht zu sagen und ich finde von der
qualität her ist es alles ein bisschen
seriöser als pes ich weiß nicht ob ihr
darum meine meinung versteht aber es
kann auch recht einfach nur
geschmackssache sein da sind jetzt
gerade zwei krippen ein zombie es kann
auch echt geschmackssache sein es ist
auch geschmackssache das muss ich muss
ich auch echt zu geben weil ich kenne
selber viele leute die sagen ja das ist
richtig geil tiefer finde ich jetzt
nicht so toll wie gesagt wenn eure
freunde alle pässe haben ist natürlich
besser sich pest zu kaufen weil also pro
evolution soccer pes ist ein komischer
name mit alle eure freunde provision
zocker haben dann ist natürlich auch
besser sich pro evolution soccer zu
holen weil er dann natürlich mit dem
zocken könnt online genauso wie bei
playstation welches xbox kauft euch das
was eure kumpels haben und was ihr
persönlich besser findet bei mir war es
damals so drei leute hatten xbox also
ich habe meine place schon ziemlich
lange ungefähr vor ein zwei jahren noch
länger 34 jahre ungefähr
und ja die ist schon sehr lange draußen
und ich habe mir die damals wirklich
gekauft keiner meiner kumpels hatten
oakley sie ich bin jetzt tot
keiner meiner freunde hatte eine play
sie aber ganz einfach ich fand das
einfach besser
es war mir egal dass ich hat mit kleinen
spielen konnte aber ich hab halt in
meiner eigenen immer meine eigene
meinung gebildet deswegen solltet ihr
eigentlich auch nicht mich fragen was
ihr euch kaufen sollt bildet euch eure
eigene meinung ihr könnt euch ein
bisschen informieren ich kann euch dann
nur ein paar leid vergeben
alles liegt die reine luft schrecklich
besser als bei skype dass nicht alle
sachen an ihm wie runter fliegen wenn
man kriegt er wieder eine regel weil man
soll nicht sterben aber habe ich schon
am anfang gesagt wir spielen ja nicht
auf hardcore ich möchte gerne sterben
und als ich will nicht unbedingt sterben
aber da schon wieder ein krieg aber ich
will die welt zumindest nachher
freigeben und da ist es natürlich auch
witziger wenn man ein paar mal stirbt
vor gut sei richtig knapp fällt jetzt
komisch an aber finde ich halt irgendwie
besser wenn man nicht so eine regel hat
so darfst nicht sterben du musst total
vorsichtig vorgehen mag ich nicht so
schächer regeln es gehört hat mich nicht
gesehen da kann ich ein bisschen
sortieren erst mal hallo ich hätte gern
reisen einfach nur für so ein paar
sachen die man sich damit kräften kann
man axt es hier so was essen bogen haben
mittlerweile mehr als genug bauen wir
auch aber ich hab das bauen wir benutze
ich jetzt mal nicht für die bäume weil
wir haben erstmal genug davon sondern
hier für weizen und so für farben usw
dann können wir die auch eigentlich
direkt ein bisschen vergrößern
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie lange das
wasser geht also ich doch drei geht das
weit oder sagt der mann in die
kommentare
wir brauchen gerade habe ich in der
kiste hier setzling hier ist noch
setzlinge brote können wir es auch
machen oder das weizen kann ich für
dingens verwenden für die kühe kann ja
so sein weil wir sonst ein komisches
links polster haben nördlich braucht ihn
wie hoch die hohe brauche ich da die
krise kann ich ja so in assam einfach
spawn fällt mir gott ein mal wieder
alles kaputt jetzt hier war
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
ja ich weiß dass gerade voll knochen
verschwendung aber es mir egal so da
kann jetzt wieder erweitern das auch
schön dann habe ich die erde schon mehr
hab ich nicht direkt vor meiner farm du
idiot
blödmann so hier kann ich eigentlich
auch noch hin bauen ja auch noch blöd
hält man perfekte moment auch noch
setzlinge schönen achten skelett hallo
ich meine knochen mail kann man
eigentlich nicht sagen verschwendung
willkommen hier sind sowas von viele
skelette
ich habe keine dinge mehr und auch keine
axt er sich auch kacke ach du scheiße
verpisst euch was wollen die alle von
mir roboter schäden im skelett online
wenn der zombies kommen die machen glaub
ich sogar die türen kaputt ich sage
jetzt mal ein paar sachen wie hoch ihr
euch kann ich mitnehmen da musste ich ja
gleich noch was mitmachen ich auf ein
schwert muss ich mir auf jeden fall
machen und dingens eine schaufel
eine schaufel tschuldigung das gab ein
bisschen dreht aber ich bin noch ein
bisschen hektik mächtig so ich hoffe mal
dass sexy bei der zweck ist okay das weg
wo ist das skelett das war auch rad
irgendwo wo ist überhaupt der mond oder
die sonne oder irgendwie was in die
richtung
ob gott jetzt damit die da hinten beide
ab nein ich hab mal so komisch
geschlagenes bank meinte zu mir dass das
besser sein aber ich habe mir nie
wirklich geglaubt muss man selber
ausprobieren
alles schön wieder hin bauen so ich kann
ich ja dann direkt hier weitermachen man
viel zu nervös jetzt viel zu heiß heute
ihren wie ihr
ich weiß nicht warum aber es ist extrem
heiß bei uns gerade und ich bin gerade
hier dabei und muss aufnehmen und 3
weil ich einfach keine partner habe ich
auch noch
kann ich nicht theoretisch ja kann ich
hier auch noch obwohl hier ein kompass
von sollte eigentlich klappen
gib mir sagen ich hab so was man keine
hobbys ich stehe einfach nur vorgemacht
dass ihr die ganze zeit hin und wieder
kaputt und so weiter so das gleiche ich
jetzt auch noch nie war das tier so
jetzt haben wir ein bisschen was
gepflanzt also eine große farm ist das
eigentlich schon für mich sag ich mal
die sachen lagern hier einfach mal
wieder wir brauchen auf jeden fall
definitiv mehr wasser übels viel weizen
das heißt wir können drohte machen
drittel was anderes kann man durch mit
reizen mittlerweile gar nicht machen
sand pfeile wo ist meine ganz anderen
pfeile
dafür habe ich noch einmal mit dem bogen
geschossen bis in essen nehme ich mir
mal mit und dann würde ich sagen mach
ich auch direkt einen aufnahmestopp und
zwar war es das dann auch schon wieder
mit diesem part ich könnte aber ein
bisschen mit dem knochenmehl rumlaufen
und ein paar bäume wachsen lassen damit
wieder ein bisschen schön aussieht war
es dann auch
ich hab gesagt mit der ersten folge ich
hab gesagt mit der ich hab ich dann auf
ersten folge
leider war es auch schon wieder hier mit
mit platz vier sind wir glaube ich
mittlerweile hier bei der sat wasteland
also ich finde bisher mein bisheriges
fazit von dieser map extrem geil o gott
war fast tot der dingens bisher mein
fazit eine extrem geile web eine richtig
geile idee ziemlich einfach nur hammer
macht doch bisher mir sehr viel spaß
merkt er glaube ich auf da kannst du
dann explodieren
ich glaube ihr merkt auch dass es mir
einfach viel spaß macht
bei meinem kommentieren ich auch fast
gar keine themen über die ich zu
quatschen kann dass ich dann auch
wirklich einfach so bei das spiel hier
quatschen weil es einfach auch extrem
viel spaß macht und ich kann mich
wirklich nur empfehlen schreibt dem
entwickler der netten gruß von mir
download euch die welt und ich würde
mich über einen daumen hoch freuen wenn
ich das wieder gefallen hat und dann
würde ich sagen ich kann noch mal ganz
kurz hier die paar bäume hier noch ich
fast gar kein baum mehr paare bisschen
verbrauchen alter wieso sind hier noch
soviel zombies ist doch tag oder einfach
nur regen und es regnet nicht in der
wüste und deswegen weil ich kann ja mal
torkel dauern ehe das ist ja so eine
alte map da geht das ja noch gar nicht
naja egal ich werde mich darum kümmern
ich würde einfach sagen wie sie in
seiner nächsten folge und ich hoffe ihr
schaltet wieder einen schönen blick ob
man nicht wieder so lange das thema um